ومع نهايه العام نستعرض وابرز المحطات
التي شهدتها الحرب على اوكرانيا في شهرها
العشره والتي بدات في فبراير التي اشتعلت
في اواخرها الحرب واحاولت قوات الروسيه
سريعا لاستيلاء على العاصمه كاف ما يميز
شهر مارس هو فشل الروس في الاستله على
العاصمه وبدا الكشف عن مقابر جماعيه عند
تخوم المدينه في بوتشا ابرز محطات شهر
ابريل هو غرقوا التراد الروسي مسكوفا
بصاروخ اوكرانيا وهو ما شكل ضربه مؤلمه
لتفوق موسكو البحرين ولم مكانتها العسكريه
اما في شهر مايو فكان شهر توسع الناته
وبدء مسيره دخول السويد وفنلندا منظومه
الحلف على الرغم من معارضه تركيا والمجد
في شهر يونيو ما الذي حصل بدات تداعيات
الحرب تاخذ مسارات اخرى مع دخول العالم
فيما يشبه الازمه الغذائيه بس في توقف
صادرات الحبوب الاوكرانيه في شهر يوليو
سقطت اخر مدينه في منطقه لوجانز تحت سيطره
الروس واعتزمن ذلك مع بدء موسكو اغلاق
خطوتي انابيب الغاز نور ستريم بشكل متكبر
لزياده الضغط على اوروبا هذه الضغوط وصلت
الى ذروتها في اغسطس مع توقفي معظم صادرات
الغاز الى اوروبا وارتفاع اسعاره بشكل
متسارع اما في شهر سبتمبر فكان شهر التعب
الجزئيه الروسيه واعلان نصف رسميا ضمه
وخرسون
ولوغانسيا الى الاتحاد الروسي في شهر
اكتوبر تم ضرب جسر القرم الرابط بين روسيا
وشبه جزيره القرم وبدات موسكو في قصف منهج
لبنيه الطاقه الاوكرانيه في شهر نوفمبر
كان شهر السعاده اوكرانيا لمدينه خرسون
وهي من اوائل
التي سقطت في ايه القوات الروسيه شهر
ديسمبر شهيده اول زياره خارجيه للرئيس
الاوكراني الى واشنطن وبعدها تصاعد جدول
التفاوض بين طرفي الحرب مستمره